Pedro good to see you man hey Carlos
good to see you too
you know it's feels like it's been like
a forever wait for this season of the
Mandalorian like we've been waiting a
real long time considering how big of an
impact the first two seasons have made
for Star Wars fans old and new alike but
did you feel like pressure going into
this season to kind of recreate a lot of
the magic you had in the last two
seasons
I think that the weight is brilliant and
they also did something wonderful where
they were able to bridge Seasons two and
season three of the Mandalorian with the
book of Boba Fett which was sort of an
extension of the world that's been
introduced to us through the series of
the Mandalorian but also
um the brilliant character that we've
come to know from very early on in the
movies Boba Fett and um and of course uh
Mando makes his appearance and is
reunited with brogu in that series which
is such a wonderful way to take us into
season three so
um it's been a good weight but we've
we've had company
we've had really good company throughout
for sure you know we've gotten so many
amazing like John fabric kind of called
them like water cooler talk moments you
know the whole internet talking about
can you believe this happened in the
episode can you believe that happened in
the episode when you see one of those
moments in the script what is your own
reaction do you have anyone that you can
talk to and be like yo this is gonna
happen or do you have to keep it all in
for yourself
this is the only one that I keep it in
which is strange it's very out of
character for me because I'm a I'm a I'm
a blabbermouth
um I tell everybody everything and uh
and I I always say to myself ah no who's
gonna say anything nobody cares that
much but with this
I didn't even tell my family one about
uh grogu
um
and two about Luke Skywalker making an
appearance in uh season two and I'm not
going to tell anybody anything about
what goes down in season three either
good night I mean yeah oh see you later
so John was saying that this chapter is
like the middle chapter of a much bigger
story and that's exciting for fans of
this show exciting for us here
um how long would you want to stay on
board with this and do you ever talk to
him and be like dude does he know the
anime does he know how this ends
if he does know how it ends he hasn't
told me
and I don't want to know necessarily I
like being surprised by what comes in as
it comes in and um this is definitely a
character more like any other that could
you know have a very very long term
uh life span as far as
me getting to play him
um
at a certain point I may not be able to
fit into the suit but there will always
be someone who can
something that I've been loving recently
is the internet rediscovering a lot of
your earlier work right whether it's
like uh goth Pedro on NYPD Blue or your
work on Buffy I do enjoy looking back
and being reminded of those moments
yeah it's great I I I've been a jobbing
actor for most of my adult life and I
love the memory of how much of a win
those jobs felt like and um kind of
build
me into who I am uh today and and it's
it's it's it's it's an interesting uh
marker of time also and I miss uh I miss
the experience of of being a guest star
on this on these very well-oiled
machines
um uh so it's a a beautiful reminder a
lot of the time yeah
well being the star of one as well open
machines can't be too bad no it's great
that's awesome thank you so much for
your time man all the best thanks Carlos